did you go back and reflect on the super
bowl watch any film yeah yeah of course
i've watched school at least five six
times
you know trying to
you know see you know or
for some reason you know you watch a
movie and just like watching the titanic
and you hope the ship
just don't sink and for some reason the
ship just keeps sinking over and over
and
um you know i go back and watch the game
you just hope that you know that
you know all the plays that
we left out there and
you know the possible opportunities you
know that we could have came out
victorious but we didn't and that's the
reality and
so now we got to move on and
look forward to next year and this
offseason i'm running and trying to get
back to try to win it again
emmanuel sanders glutton for punishment
watching the super bowl over and over
again and hoping for a different result
but knowing that at the end of the day
like in titanic
the ship
sinks i don't know what makes him do
that chris i would think the more likely
reaction is i don't want to see it i i
mean yes yes and no
i think as a player you know your first
you're proud to be in the super bowl you
want to watch it back a little just hey
what did it look like on tv
things like that
and yeah what could i have done
differently what plays did it really
come down to oh man if we just made this
play we win the super bowl i do think
there's a number of players out there
that will torture themselves that way
and then the other half will be like you
said never gonna watch it never gonna
look at it ever again he seems to be a
guy that can stomach it now he's won one
before too so that takes the edge off of
it a little bit and the fact that he's
done that and he can at least maybe
swallow this one a little easier than a
guy you know like joe staley who's been
there twice and hasn't won it yet he
might be sick to even think about it or
looking at it but i mean
this is why like we don't see a lot of
super bowl losers bounce back the next
year right i mean this this is why it's
you think about it you go oh man it's
been a long year i need to rest you know
then you have a little bit of a pity
party for yourself and your team and
and meanwhile the team that won it is
like oh this is awesome this is
addicting i want to get back and you
almost because you won it also gives you
the energy to you know get into the off
season work and let's go where the team
that loses it kind of gets in the
offseason work is like uh yeah well
let's get to work but you know they're
kind of feeling down still about losing
the super bowl
we're five years removed now from the
ultimate deflating loss when the
seahawks had the game won against the
patriots right they threw instead of
calling a run and it was intercepted by
malcolm butler and and and it was damage
control for months by the seahawks to
get guys who were upset with how things
went back on the same page i mentioned
that because
if you have a guy like emmanuel sanders
who's due to become a free agent who is
overly dissecting what went wrong and
will have some strong opinions about
what went wrong including being open
after he split a double team and was
there to catch the game-winning
potentially touchdown pass but jimmy
garoppolo missed him does sanders become
a guy that you can't keep around because
you know
that he could be a potential negative
presence because he's still upset about
what happened in the super bowl well if
you get a sense that that is the type of
guy he is that's going to carry this and
continue to point fingers and do things
like that i want to say continue because
he hasn't pointed fingers at all yet i
don't mean to me but he's already
watched the thing six times he's not
going to come out of it saying oh it was
fine hey stuff happens the chiefs won
the game we didn't lose the game he'll
be able to point the reasons why they
lost well yeah he definitely will be yes
but i think he's been around enough and
mature enough too to kind of keep those
things to himself and just kind of shake
his head in the locker room here these
last few days and hey what's wrong oh
man i still can't believe we lost you
know i think that's in the natural dna
of a lot of football players i think
that's probably within in him anyways
now if you're the head coach and you
feel like he's a guy that won't be able
to handle his emotions yes then you have
to think about that also i would say
mike he's probably on the borderline
anyways of coming back regardless you
know he's getting to that age where you
know yeah do you really want to pay for
a guy like emmanuel sanders at this
point of his career and pay him big
money they do have other young wide
receivers on their roster so i think he
will be one of their bigger decisions
here in the next few weeks is whether
just you know keep him and try to get a
deal done for free agency or move on and
let some of these young guys kind of
move up the ranks
yeah i i look i i i think there's going
to be a lot of decisions in the 49ers
what do you think what do you think what
goes on with the niners like what's your
feel like we've had a lot of gut of like
what we expect from the chiefs you tell
me i always like your gut your gut's
pretty good well here's look i i just i
just sent a text on the pft live chain
to see where in the show i can ask you
this question i'm gonna ask you the
question right now okay
i'm gonna go there i'm gonna do it yes i
am
you being hanging around you're too much
yeah i'm mocking you
yeah are you doing here's the question
here's the question right
tom brady picks up the phone and calls
kyle yeah and says hey i grew up in
northern california i was a huge 49ers
fan i'm getting toward the end of my
career
i think i can help you guys get over the
hump in 2020 i'd like to play for you
what do you think kyle says
i think kyle would be like wow man
that's you know i respect
you know you saying that you know let me
think about it i think he probably would
say that he'd probably talk to john
lynch a little bit have a conversation i
think ultimately he would go back with
jimmy garoppolo
because one he can sit here and go wait
i don't know if necessarily tom brady's
better than jimmy garoppolo two you know
it might be just one year with tom brady
or two years and then it start from
scratch again anyway so that would be my
my
thought hi i'm mike tarico and thanks
for watching make sure to hit subscribe
for the latest news and highlights from
nbc sports